stan lee is promoting nfts now which
might surprise you because stan lee is
dead but his official twitter account
begs to differ quote from championing
diversity to embracing new tech stan was
always one step ahead of the curve to
honor his innovative spirit stan's first
indian hero chakra the invincible debuts
in his own nft digital art collection
and then we have a link here now listen
to take a dead man and use him to prop
up your garbage profile picture nft
collection might seem bad but i promise
you it gets way worse starting with the
art which features stan lee smiling from
beyond the grave an alien version of his
superhero for no other reason than to
prop up this 6000 profile picture
collection i mean the crazy thing is
they try to make this sound like by
buying this you're honoring stan's
legacy somehow check out this trash
honoring what would have been stan's
99th birthday on december 28th we are
inviting all of stan's fans to celebrate
his amazing legacy with us by sharing
ownership in a limited nft collectible
around one of his first international
superheroes
wow
they're saying hey if you want to
celebrate this guy's um what would have
been his birthday just reminding you
that he's dead buy our stuff and if
you're wondering how this is honoring
stan lee's legacy in any way um you're
not the only one the website who created
this seems to have popped up after stan
lee was dead like they weren't even
around when he was alive the company so
it seems like uh you know after the body
was cold
these guys had their little idea for an
nft collection to put together and i say
that because it's not like stan lee had
been a collaborator on this nft project
and like died while signing digitally
the last nft that was not the case i
want to make that really clear this is
not like when a musician releases music
after they die that they weren't able to
finish i mean that's already a little
bit weird but no this is like hey you
died some dudes come around try to find
a way to make money with your stuff and
just drop nfts and use your twitter
profile to promote it i mean this thing
is so bad all around that pretty much
everyone agreed this was pretty trash
dull and dark can't believe stan lee
came back from the dead just to promote
an nft
schlatt said that's the power of
blockchain jacksepticeye this is so
awful and then we have this meme but
there's one other detail here that i
think most people missed which is that
the name of the nft platform they're
selling these nfts on
will blow your mind you can't make this
up the name of the nft platform that is
bringing back stan lee from beyond the
grave to sell these crappy nfts is
called beyond life dot club
i kid you not watch this is their thing
an exclusive uh you know nft collection
from beyond i thought they're gonna say
from beyond the grave from beyond human
possibilities launching soon
only at beyond life dot club guys
stan lee has officially entered the
beyond life dot club this is such a
travesty such a gross desecration of
this man's life you know i just think
it's gross not only because he never
promoted these nfts but also because
this the whole thing could turn out to
be a scam only a couple of weeks ago
they were saying that people were having
trouble withdrawing from this platform
the platform that they're selling these
things on so this could absolutely
become an a total scam either way it's
one of the grossest things i've seen in
a while taking one of the most all-time
beloved figures taking their twitter
account from beyond the grave and using
it to shill a quick cash grab on your
website beyond life dot club all in the
name of their 99th birthday completely
gross one of the most disgusting things
i've seen and i hope people don't buy
this that's all i wanted to say bye